hello my name is Caleb and I'm I'm David
I'm Stephanie and we are medical
students and we're here to answer your
questions today are you able to have a
social life outside of school honestly
you would not survive medical school
unless you were able to do that I think
there's there's plenty of time to have a
social life that's ahead school studying
together is one thing but just hanging
out and like decompressing together is
so important it's a really good way to
avoid burnout and that's stay sane
yeah that's so fun do you still check
web web and MD when you don't feel well
no no no no we are super against Web MD
there's this website called up to date
basically like Wikipedia for doctors so
now instead of going to WebMD I'm just
like up to date and you just start with
no like a medical jargon and it gives
you a whole thing I will check WebMD and
then I'll compare it and I'll be like
okay do these look consistent do they
look inconsistent and stuff like that
you know do you rely on coffee to keep
you going yeah under percent yes every
single day there's a schedule too it's
like for three months coffee and then
two week break so that it works again I
drink probably like one company have you
ever successfully diagnosed yourself
with something no but I have
successfully misdiagnosed myself with a
bunch of things not yet unless like
anxiety comes I like threw all my back
when I was lifting how did you know you
wanted to be a doctor / go into the
health field that's a hard one the med
school interview I know right my dad's a
scientist and my mom is an engineer and
I was really bad at computers as a kid
so I was like maybe I'll go be a
scientist and then I got really
interested in like you know well outside
of science you know medicine is a very
science heavy field and as I explored
that in college kind of found my way
there to me what I like about it is it's
like a puzzle like you have a patient
come in
and you have this like very limited
amount of information into your job to
kind of pull out what you need to so
I've always been really interested in
that I think for me I was sick a lot as
a kid and I really wanted to be someone
that can help someone else in that
situation I wasn't really sure until
probably high school and I wasn't like
this at this magnet school we had a
health science program during our third
year we would go to the hospital I'm
like shadow doctors and things like that
and I thought it was really cool what
was your least favorite part of Medical
School step one step one also that step
one is is the first in a series of exams
that we get to take because I like of
our licensure as doctors it's the basic
science one where take ask you all these
questions about how disease processes
work things like that and the beauty of
it it they can ask you anything and say
you study everything just memorizing
random stuff that feels super irrelevant
what is actually super gratifying as I'm
going into the hospital and shadowing or
doing rotations or whatever that kind of
like puts it back into perspective
craziest / grossest cadavers story we
have a half of a head and it's
plastinated but you can see every part
of it like the nose hairs the eyelashes
every single part of the space and my
professor will just hold it up to his
face just to show you where it's
supposed to be as it is I so it just
grosses me out when I work you like
grabs it with his bare hands and just
like this is a face there's one day
where they had us do a fresh tissue a
fresh body like procedure not a
procedure but just studying a fresh body
so there was no like preserving fluid or
anything and a lot of the smells were or
the bonafide smells
they weren't sated with and they warned
us yeah they even gave us like Vaseline
to put on her upper lip so that we could
block out the smell and everything the
short of it is we had a guy say what
kind of doctor do you want to be and why
I want to be a cancer doctor so I'm
extremely interested in helping patients
with cancer just because I've had a lot
of cancer death in my family I had to
choose right now probably a psychiatrist
I feel like I'm more open like I think
that a lot of people go into med school
thinking that
they know what kind of doctor they want
to be but there's also a lot of people
were going like thinking they know it
and then later on change their mind so
I'm pretty open to different kind of
fields I think I want to go into
internal medicine which is basically
just adult people doctor does it get
annoying when your friends or family ask
for medical advice nobody really asked
me for medical advice yes because I
don't know a lot of things so I end up
googling a ton of things it's funny
because whenever people ask me no matter
how private or gross it might be it's
like in all the boundaries of friendship
or fun when people ask me about medical
problems what is something you wish you
knew before you started med school
I kind of wish I knew how much time I
was gonna spend studying I guess I
didn't think too much about that
find the balance early otherwise it's
gonna get too crazy too fast what's the
hardest part of the med school I think
staying motivated yeah that's true
staying on track with the study schedule
finding a plan and a routine that works
for you and like sticking to it
step 1 yes that was step 1 is it true
that a lot of med students experiment
with drugs and caffeine all the time
caffeine
yeah I wouldn't say experiment have you
ever tried to diagnose friends or family
yeah yes what is something you've
learned in med school that you weren't
expecting to I think it's the doctoring
class that we were talking about like I
didn't know that you have to learn how
to talk like a doctor we started doing
clinical skills practice and like
learning how to talk to patients and
take history is really early on like in
our first two weeks in medical school so
that was I wasn't expecting that but I'm
super grateful well it keeps you
motivated when school gets really hard I
talked to my mom every day she really
grounds me I'm super close to my mom I
think being in the hospital and seeing
patients kind of helps balance that for
me because it's so easy to get to not've
ated when you're like I have all this
crap to learn I don't care anymore I'm
tired I just want
sleep but then remembering like oh wait
the thing that I learned right now will
help me take care of a patient better
and faster I just think about how like
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
it might be like a lot of pressure right
now but ultimately you know you'll get
through it and at the end of the day
they're like a brighter day oh they're
just looking forward to the goal do you
practice a lot of techniques and
learnings on each other like taking
blood I thought it was gonna fail out of
med school because in the in the first
like two months of medical so the first
you need to do is draw each other's
blood and I'm so scared of meals I know
I know I'm trying to be a doctor but I'm
scared of needles I think was a lot of
good stories wrong when I was doing it
with my friend and and she did it on me
first and I've got huge veins so it's
like it's pretty easy you stick it in
there it's fine and then it was my turn
to do it her and I like I missed the
vein and I like oh my god I feel like a
lot of times in medical school you feel
like I don't even know how I got chosen
to be here I feel like they gave the
wrong person the acceptance letter or
something like that you have this like
what is it like imposter imposter
syndrome when you execute up there like
you're gonna have imposter syndrome but
it's gonna be okay but everyone has it
everyone feels this and all I can say is
if you got into medical school like you
can do it like they they already know
that you can do it
[Music]